i asked last week when the news came out
that tom brady had accidentally wandered
into someone's house in tampa when he
was supposed to be meeting with byron
leftwich what gives you're not supposed
to be meeting with assistant coaches
prior to the start of the off season
program brady supposedly walked into
this guy's house dropped a couple of
duffel bags onto the floor which likely
included footballs and uh when i asked
the nfl about it last week they said
nothing i asked about it again yesterday
they issued a statement that they looked
into it no violation of any kind
committed by tom brady or the buccaneers
in meeting with byron leftwich because
all he was doing was picking up a
playbook something they could put on a
tablet and send to his house
he had to go pick it up directly from
byron leftwich that's their story they
stuck to it and the nfl bought it and if
you if you can't tell i'm being
sarcastic because i think there's a hell
of a lot more here that they don't want
to delve into because they don't want to
disrupt the happy vibe in tampa bay
that accompanies the arrival of tom
brady peter
yeah i mean you know by the absolute
letter of the law that such a meeting
shouldn't happen and i don't know what
happened in terms of you know what each
party said i'm sure the nfl called uh
either left witch or brady or aryans and
found out you know the the gist of all
this
mike
i mean to me this is one of those
stories that
um
i think i'm not saying it's complicated
but i'm also
making the point that
you could probably also argue
that in the 10 or 12 one-hour zoom chats
that uh that the coach of the cincinnati
bengals zach taylor had with joe burrow
that they weren't just asking about his
background and his hobbies and
everything
they're getting stuff done about the
cincinnati bengals offense
so
i've always thought that once april
rolls around
uh and and a guy is property of a new
team or whatever i've always thought
that that is exactly like the legal
tampering period
more happens than should happen in that
legal tampering period and if they would
have uh sanctioned uh the tampa bay
buccaneers
in in my opinion and i'm not i
if they had sanctioned the tampa bay
buccaneers for this i think they could
have easily
opened up a case on every one of the
other 31 teams and found something quite
similar um i'm not saying everyone but
but and i shouldn't say everyone but a
lot of them they would have found
something similar
well like yeah okay so i don't buy it
like i'm throwing the al river on
challenge flag okay i mean you know
again
mike you made the points yeah they could
have just hey tom download this on your
ipad here's our playbook bam you know
the duffel bags i think they were
footballs that would be my assessment
just being an ex quarterback and being
that way where i would think he might
have gone to bayern leftwich's house and
maybe they were going to have a little
bit of a walk through and do go through
some of the mechanics at the line of
scrimmage or even lightly drop back and
he throws a ball to byron leftwich which
is a play that's going to be instilled
in the offense my big thing is this
like
it's a stupid rule like nfl get the hell
out of here with these rules
how are you going to tell 43 year old
man how hard he can work and how great
he wants to be i mean this is tom freak
and brady would you think he was going
to go down there and just sip pina
coladas and be like
i'll learn the offense at some point
guys
this is great what a great son jane i
got no he wants to be great he wants to
win a super bowl and shove it in
everybody's face this year get rid of
these stupid rules nfl i broke them
every year i played i would break them
every time now you're not going to tell
me when i'm going to learn more football
and get better as a player like shut up
with that crap
first of all remind me to never drink
pina coladas with you i don't know what
your pina colada consumption style is
but i think pina colada ends up will
getting everywhere when you glug it like
that
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems i have with the nfl and this is
the way the nfl finds a way to trip over
its own shoelaces constantly they set up
these rules that don't reflect reality
and so
you have these rules that you can't
enforce because when you do enforce them
you look stupid like when they whacked
the chiefs a few years ago for talking
directly to jeremy macklin during the
legal tampering window when they can
only talk to his agent they're not
supposed to talk to the player oh you
talk to the player you have to give up a
third round pick and 500 thousand
dollars in fines it's ridiculous because
everybody does it bounty gate everybody
was doing something similar to what the
saints allegedly were doing the list
goes on and on and on of instances where
the nfl reaches in like the claw and
just grabs one team and makes an example
out of them for breaking a rule that
everybody breaks and that otherwise
isn't enforced so i'm with you chris i
hate to say it i hate to agree with you
on anything but just get rid of these
stupid rules or make the rules better
reflect reality because then you have to
look the other way when you catch
someone red-handed that's the problem
they caught the bucks red-handed and
chris and chris and i have been hearing
all the rumors about all the stuff
that's going on down in tampa to get
hashtag tommy ready for the season and
this may just be scratching the surface
when he accidentally walks into someone
else's house and he was going to meet
with byron leftwich but but just if
you're not going to enforce the rules
then get rid of them all right another
important point as it relates to the
buccaneers peter and this came up over
the weekend sean payton inadvertently
during the draft-a-thon gave chris and i
a topic that we milked uh until the
utter was dry yesterday sean payton's
belief that at any given time there are
only 10 or 11 relevant teams in the nfl
the others just simply don't have a
realistic shot at winning the super bowl
the 10 or 11 relevant teams are the ones
you have to worry about when they're on
your calendar
does the presence of tom brady with the
tampa bay buccaneers and we can throw
gronk on top of that too now but mainly
brady does that take the buccaneers and
move them
from the category of irrelevant team to
relevant team peter your thoughts
absolutely unequivocally yes and it's
relevant both in terms of marketing and
fandom and all that and also on the
field we've talked about this before on
this show mike and that is that the
tampa bay buccaneers last december were
on a four game winning streak and had
two home games left against houston and
atlanta
i would argue that absolutely
unequivocally they should have finished
nine and seven jameis winston lost two
nail biters by throwing six
interceptions including a walk-off pick
on the first play of overtime uh to lose
the game to the atlanta falcons so i
would argue that this was already
with the most mistake-prone quarterback
of modern times this was already a
nine-win team
and so
to think that tom brady can't get him to
10 or 11 with the addition of rob
gronkowski whatever they get from him
with a young and growing defense
uh i i mean how can they not be one of
the most relevant teams in football
well yeah i mean i listen i i agree with
that they're they're in that
conversation you know again now do i put
them in there and where i go you know
organizational wise okay are they on the
same platform as the chiefs the ravens
the patriots the packers the eagles on a
year-to-year basis no i don't think
they've proven to us yet and i think i
still think that's what sean payton was
talking about was more on the big scope
big picture of things there's 10 teams
that he's worried about being able to
build a credible winner year after year
and being able to sustain consistently
being relevant in the nfl and tampa i'm
not going to put them in that class but
when you just talk about the 10 or 11
relevant teams to the particular year
yes they're definitely in it this year i
mean to peter's point this is a team i
think a lot of people put a little mark
next to last year to go oh watch out for
the bucks next year and then when you
make some of the additions they have in
free agency and the tom brady to what
both of you are saying i mean this is
going to raise the level of the whole
organization you know again we're seeing
what tom brady's work ethic is about we
just talked about it he's willing to
break rules and do whatever the hell he
wants to do to get to become a better
player and to make that team better and
i'm all for that so keep breaking those
damn rules tom the hell with all that
crap and uh yes i think they are very
relevant this year and i think going to
be in the mix very much so when it comes
playoff time
this is a very rare occasion though for
the tampa bay buccaneers to have a
quarterback who's a short timer a head
coach who's clearly a short timer they
all kind of come together
for this brief moment one year two years
three at the absolute maximum and then
on the horizon major changes for the
buccaneers organization coming but hey
it's better than what they've been
pretty much every year since 2002 when
they won the super bowl so they'll take
it it'll fill the stadium once we're
allowed to have fans in the stadium
it'll sell jerseys it'll win games and
it makes the tampa bay buccaneers for
now extremely relevant and look with
every nfl season being a one year at a
time proposition
you know yeah you'd rather be a team
that contends each and every year but
when you don't contend each and every
year if it falls into your lap for one
year you take it it's kind of like it's
it's not entirely the same but it's
similar to what the vikings had with
brett favre for a season
um right the idea that that that hey
we're not going to say no to the
opportunity to join forces peter with an
all-time great quarterback and see where
it takes us and we'll worry about
tomorrow when tomorrow comes
how great would it be if tampa bay
buccaneers head coach byron leftwich
right before the 2023 draft that he and
uh general manager jason light trade a
two and a four to green bay
for 39 year old quarterback
how great would that be
that would be amazing
i like it just just
time it out over the next 15 or 20 years
catch every great quarterback on the
tail end of his career for a couple of
seasons and then just move on to the
next one i kind of like
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports